[Music]
thank you
during the time of the dinosaurs the
skies were dominated by flying reptiles
called pterosaurs
there were over 250 species
and some of them were enormous
[Music]
one of the most interesting because
they're the most bizarre are the ashdaki
pterosaurs and to try and describe what
a national architerrister is like is
very difficult
they stand as tall as giraffes
they've got heads that may have been two
meters long
s of 10 meters
they're just some of the most bizarre
things who have ever evolved on Earth
despite their size these Giants were
well adapted for flight
so why do we think they hunted on the
ground
the as dark its wing is a skin membrane
supported entirely by a super enlarged
fourth finger
this skin membrane extended from the tip
of that giant fourth finger all the way
to the top of the hind leg
as dark kids were supremely adapted for
covering great distance but they weren't
the kind of animals that were twisting
and turning and making agile movements
actually in flight
this would have made it hard for as dark
heads to catch other flying animals
they must have had a different way to
hunt
one of the most prevalent ideas about
how azed architerosols may have fed is
by using this bizarre mechanism of
foraging known as Skin feeding
[Music]
birds like black skimmers feed in this
way
it's the most ridiculous way of getting
your food you can imagine it is
literally pushing your lorage all
through the water and crashing into your
food
now skimmer's neck is built to absorb
sudden impacts
but fossils reveal as darkians had none
of these adaptations
in fact they would you almost certainly
break their necks from just the strain
of trying to push their lower Jaws
through the water
and as darkid had no option
it must have landed to find food
but could it really walk fast enough to
hunt
scientists needed evidence to persuade
them that it could do anything more than
just waddle
that evidence comes from 66 million year
old footprints
the biggest aerosol track in the world
was made by a walking giant Asian arcade
that's not only a cool thing to have it
tells us an awful lot about how
efficient they were at walking
they're their body
giving them an upright stance
their feet were padded
and unlike the small pterosaurs their
long legs gave them an enormous stride
Although our star kids are peculiar
looking animals they're moving very
efficiently
as dark it's combine this very competent
terrestrial walking ability with this
massive long stalk-like face
they almost certainly were predators
that walked around reaching down to grab
animals
to remember that this throat side of
this thing is half a meter wide that's
about the width of my shoulders
we would be on the menu for these things
if they were alive today
pterosaurs would have been an
awe-inspiring sight in the sky
or even more impressive and terrifying
on the ground
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign